[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité
économique écologique et si vous louiez
votre sapin de Noël en ce mois de
décembre l'idée se développe dans la
Sarthe chaque année les mêmes familles
retrouve le même sapin nous expliquera
LMTv Sarthe dans quelques instants
TV5 Monde diffusera le 11 décembre une
série d'émissions appelées philoscopie
présentée par le philosophe Tom Benoît
les invités exceptionnels Jean Nouvel et
Michel Onfray sont dans cette émission
environ un extrait dans un instant dans
ce journal
elles sont toutes légendaires font rêver
n'importe quelle automobiliste les plus
belles voitures du monde ont rendez-vous
chaque année à Monaco pour le salon Top
Marques un événement dans lequel s'est
glissé la caméra de Christophe Rigaud
pour l'émission monte-carl rivière
extrait à découvrir dans ce journal et
puis enfin l'édition la rédaction de via
Occitanie nous emmènera dans les allées
féeriques du festival des lanternes de
Montauban un événement magique et un
voyage tout en lumière vers la Chine
mais ils ont débuté ce journal avec
cette action en faveur de
l'environnement il est désormais
possible de louer son sapin de Noël le
principe est simple au lieu de vous
débarrasser de votre conifère à la fin
des fêtes celui-ci est stocké et
entretenu dans une pépinière en
attendant l'hiver prochain une idée qui
séduit de plus en plus de familles comme
vous allez le voir avec ce sujet
d'Anthony Python pour LM TV Sarthe
des sapins alloués pour Noël c'est le
concept de ce pépinieriste du Nord
Sarthe il vous fournit l'arbre dans un
pot et après les fêtes de fin d'année il
récupère le sapin et le replant jusqu'au
Noël suivant
la première année les gens payent la
valeur du sapin de façon ce qui soit
responsable du sapin s'ils n'ont pas du
tout arrosé chez eux donc il va revenir
complètement sec et donc en fin de
compte on lui met un petit numéro
sur le sapin et il le récupère le même
tous les ans économique donc en plus
d'être écologique ce matin beaucoup de
clients viennent avec leur ticket de
l'an dernier chaque point je le
reconnais avec cette partie là cette
partie là qui pousse un petit peu
d'année en année et de fil en aiguille
la plupart de ces particuliers
s'attachent alors sapin il le retrouve
alors avec plaisir au monde et fête ça
nous déchirait chaque année de jeter un
sapin et devoir mourir à sapin donc là
le concept de récupérer chaque année le
même et de le voir grandir finalement
voilà c'est un membre de les amis à part
entière donc c'est chouette le sapin a
quelques marques de la canicule mais
c'est pas grave pour moi ça compte pas
du tout ce qui est important c'est qu'on
puisse le retrouver le réembellir le
retrouver chaque année c'est super
ludovic a lancé l'idée il y a 6 ans
d'année en année la location de sapin
fait de plus en plus des mules là on a
déjà 620 personnes de l'année dernière
on en a trop à peu près 300 nouveaux
c'est pas mal c'est après voilà c'est la
manutention et si le sapin devient trop
grand le pépiniériste peut vous
l'échanger contre un plus petit le vieux
sapin sera alors planté en terre
définitivement
voilà et en dessous de votre beau sapin
dans deux semaines désormais vous
trouverez des cadeaux déposés par le
Père Noël une mission pour laquelle il
peut compter chaque année sur l'aide de
la poste le mois de décembre est
évidemment crucial pour l'acheminement
des colis en Moselle les équipes
s'activent pour traiter des milliers de
paquets par jour reportage dans un
centre de tri avec Coline l'expert pour
Moselle télévision
18600 colis vont défiler sur ce tapis en
l'espace de quelques heures ici ils sont
triés avant d'être dispatchés par
secteur mais speltre Richmond Fameck ou
encore Ennery les employés de la Poste
balayent 142 communes en Moselle après
avoir été scanné les colis sont
récupérés par les opérateurs et pour
livrer tout le monde à l'heure il faut
se lever tôt maintenant je suis arrivée
à 6h j'ai fait du tri et j'ai trié ma
tournée après j'ai tout chargé dans mon
camion et là je pars en tournée je pars
à 133 colis et 86 points de passage les
camionnettes sont effectivement bien
chargés quelques jours seulement après
le Black Friday cette journée de
promotion sonne d'ailleurs le début du
rush de fin d'année pour la Poste
d'environ 12000 colis triés puis livrés
depuis l'agence de Woippy le trafic va
aussi entre 15 et 20 000 colis par
journée jusqu'au 24 décembre une forte
hausse de l'activité qui nécessite des
aménagements
en livraison
normal sur la période de Noël on va
faire appel à des renforts on va louer
des véhicules donc là on a 12 CDD et on
a CDI trois agents pour la pour la
période et on loue également entre 4 et
5 véhicules supplémentaires et en
rotation camion de 3 camions livraison
qui arrive ici en agence en moyenne
chacun chargé à 3500 4000 colis on passe
à 6 camions qui nous livrent en cette
fin d'année le nombre de paquets envoyé
entre particulier passe d'environ 10 à
15%. et qu'elle soit envoyée par leur
famille ou des grandes marques ces
commandes sont encore plus attendues
qu'habituellement par les clients ils
ont peur de pas être présent ils nous
disent à demain je dois recevoir un
colis je serai peut-être pas là donc on
leur dit mais aussi non vous nous
laissez un mot disons si vous voulez
qu'on laisse chez un voisin ou vous
pouvez aller sur le site de la Poste
demander un autre jour alors pas de
temps à perdre pour Perrine aussi
attendu que le Père Noël c'est l'heure
de partir en tournée
voilà et en ces temps compliqué les
associations sont elles aussi très
mobilisées l'une des plus emblématiques
et sans aucun doute les restos du cœur
l'an passé la structure créée par
Coluche à distribué plus de 140 millions
de repas un chiffre qui pourrait être
malheureusement battu cette année avec
la hausse constatée du nombre de
bénéficiaires dans certains territoires
c'est le cas notamment dans les
Côtes-d'Armor reportage de Mathilde
quéménères pour Tébéo la chaîne du
groupe Le Télégramme sur place en
Bretagne
ce qu'on vous propose c'est de faire le
point à la fin du mois de janvier nous
direz si vous avez retrouvé du travail
la 38e campagne d'hiver des Restos du
Coeur est lancé ces deux bénévoles
étudient la situation des nouvelles
personnes qui se présentent avec une
nouveauté cette année la prise en compte
des charges énergétiques dans le barème
de l'association les gens venaient déjà
avec leur facture on les regardait bien
sûr mais officiellement ne pouvait pas
prendre en compte totalement ses charges
là ce qui fait qu'en prenant en compte
ces nouveaux éléments on arrive
désormais à accepter quasiment toutes
les demandes des familles pour cette
jeune maman par exemple l'augmentation
des prix n'était plus tenable ce matin
il pousse la porte des Restos du cœur
pour la première fois avec la crise et
tout ça c'est devenu compliqué de se
nourrir et de s'habiller ou d'acheter
des choses pour notre enfant ça augmente
très vite le lait les couches donc c'est
vrai que les vaisseaux du coeur allègent
beaucoup mon budget l'association Satan
une augmentation très importante du
nombre de personnes accueillies on a
fait un reste sur trois départements
pilote par rapport à notre changement de
barème et on aura une augmentation qui
va se situer entre 20 et 30%. en
parallèle les bénévoles pointent un
volume de denrées à distribuer en
diminution depuis 2018 j'ai constaté
qu'il y avait beaucoup moins de
marchandises ah ben il y a des fois où
j'ai fermé complètement le rideau où
j'avais pas dit il y a rien du tout dans
les magasins la ramasse est moins
importante je crois que les magasins ont
développé aussi
l'anti-gaspique il y a des rayons
antigasmiques c'est une bonne chose il
s'agit pas de critiquer donc de fait on
a moins de choses et les centres des
Restos du Coeur sont aussi en recherche
de bénévoles on compte sur vous un
slogan qui n'a jamais été autant
d'actualité
Jean-Pierre Raffarin était l'invité
jeudi matin de l'émission Face au
territoire sur TV5 Monde l'ex Premier
ministre et notamment revenu sur la
situation de son ancien parti les
républicains encore à la recherche d'un
leader incontesté cette semaine écoutez
cette extrait on connaît donc maintenant
le nom des deux finalistes de la course
pour la présidence des républicains les
républicains un parti qui est issu d'une
famille politique qui a longtemps été
celle au sein de laquelle vous avez
évolué occupé de de très nombreuses
responsabilités on se dit donc que vous
ne devez pas être insensible à ce qui
s'y passe encore aujourd'hui alors ça
vous inspire quoi ce duel entre Bruno
Retailleau d'un côté et ericciotti de
l'autre qu'est-ce que ça vous dit de
l'avenir de cette famille politique qui
a été la vôtre
je pense que cette famille politique est
en très grande difficulté
moi je l'ai quitté quand elle a refusé
dans l'action présidentielle pas la
précédente mais celle d'avant de faire
un choix entre Le Pen et Macron donc
j'ai trouvé ça inacceptable c'était pas
le message ni de Giscard ni de Chirac
donc j'ai quitté cette famille ce match
là ça me paraît pas être le match de
l'avenir c'est un match qui est un match
d'appareil le vrai match il a toujours
été le même c'est le match des
orléansistes des UDF et des
bonapartistes des RPS Édouard Philippe
c'est Laurent Wauquiez pour les
bonapartistes essayoir pour les
organismes donc tout ce qui s'anime
aujourd'hui sur l'appareil c'est quelque
chose qui est intéressant mais enfin
c'est pas la première division voilà
face au territoire avec Jean-Pierre
Raffarin est à voir ou à revoir sur le
site internet de TV5 Monde et des
partenaires de l'émission Ouest-France
Nice Matin France anti 20 minutes et
Centre France la Montagne TV tout le
monde qui diffusera d'ailleurs dès le 11
décembre une série d'émissions appelée
philoscopie présentée par le philosophe
et essayiste Tom Benoît le premier
numéro abordera de nombreuses
problématiques architecturales et
urbanistiques avec deux invités
exceptionnels Jean Nouvel très rare la
télévision et Michel Onfray extrait de
l'émission
donc je ne pense pas que ce soit que la
ville elle soit
obligatoirement libéral d'une part
d'autre part quand vous dites la ville
c'est l'argent la campagne aussi si vous
n'avez pas d'argent dans les campagnes
il faut dire que c'est plus dilué et
plus direct parce que quand je parle
d'argent je voudrais apporter une
définition par rapport à l'argent je
pense que toute monnaie toute traduction
financière en tout cas représente de
l'énergie la catastrophe aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a trop fil architecture la
banalise donc on assiste à la mort de
l'architecture alors est-ce qu'on manque
également ça veut dire qu'il faut
revenir à ces discussions théoriques du
début du 20e siècle et la différence
entre construction et architecture la
condition de possibilités des énergies
douces c'est l'énergie nucléaire sans
énergie nucléaire pas de possibilité de
frimer avec les écologies douces bon moi
je dise vous voulez vraiment faire des
efforts alors on dit oh là là Poutine le
grand méchant il va falloir absolument
que qu'on qu'on invente quelque chose
parce qu'on va pas pouvoir se passer de
son gars il va falloir qu'on se passe de
son gaz donc il va falloir que dans les
foyers on puisse baisser d'un degré tout
le monde là il va falloir etc et moi je
propose un truc formidable six mois sans
ordinateur
heloscopie une émission donc à découvrir
à partir du 11 décembre à 17h30 sur TV5
Monde
sans transition dans ce journal prenons
la direction de la Haute-Savoie ou la
ville d'Annecy vient d'inaugurer une
douzaine de casiers solidaire cette
initiative venue du Portugal permet aux
personnes sans abri de disposer d'un
endroit sécurisé pour entreposer leurs
affaires un casier est une clé
symbolique pour des personnes éloignées
parfois des habitudes sociales les plus
basiques précisions et explications avec
ce reportage de Victoria Lopez pour 8
Mont-Blanc sur place
un endroit pour abriter ses effets
personnels cela peut paraître bien peu
de choses mais quand on vit dans la rue
un casier peut faire toute la différence
pour permettre aux sans-abri de stocker
leurs affaires la ville d'Annecy a
installé 12 cases comme celle-ci si le
concept est né au Portugal il est porté
en France par l'association Emmaüs
alternative le casier solidaire c'est
une clé vers la sortie de rue en fait
c'est la possibilité pour une personne
qui vit à la rue de mettre à l'abri ses
effets personnels à la fois les sacs
avec ces quelques vêtements son sac de
couchage et souvent le plus important
c'est quelques papiers des justificatifs
anciens domicile une pièce d'identité
pouvoir mettre tout ça à l'abri parce
que pour un sans domicile fixe le risque
de vol entre père sur les effets
personnels il peut être important les
casiers seront proposés aux 100 abris
par l'Armée du Salut lors de ses maraude
ce qui souhaite en bénéficier seront
orientés vers le CCAS le Centre Communal
d'Action Sociale qui leur remettra une
clé la symbolique de la clé est très
importante et on le voit dans
l'expérience qu'on a depuis 4 ans sur
Montreuil
depuis quatre ans on exploite 24 casiers
solidaires sur Montreuil il n'y a jamais
eu de perte de clés en 4 ans en fait
c'est presque un des biens les plus
précieux que vont récupérer ces
personnes qui gardent souvent autour du
cou avec une dragonne et qui garde
précieusement parce que à l'intérieur
c'est leurs affaires la ville d'Annecy a
choisi deux emplacements pour ces
casiers l'un sur la place des Romains et
l'autre à l'angle de l'avenue du Rhône
et de l'avenue de l'overschi la première
exigence c'était d'être près des sans
domicile fixe c'est-à-dire près du
centre-ville le deuxième chose c'est
qu'il fallait que ce soit un endroit
vous pouvez passer facilement la police
municipale parce qu'il était pas
question que ça fasse des attroupements
et ça crée de nouveaux problèmes de
nouvelles zones de problèmes la
troisième chose c'est que il fallait que
ça soit sur des terrains de la ville et
il fallait que d'autre part les
monuments historiques nous donnent
l'autorisation la Ville estime à 200 le
nombre de personnes en errant dans ces
rues la municipalité a investi près de
40 000 euros pour l'installation de ces
casiers solidaires
une action pour l'insertion sociale qui
nous amène à parler à présent d'une
toute nouvelle récompense littéraire le
concours des détenus appuyé sur le
fameux prix Goncourt cette première
édition dévoilera son lauréat le 15
décembre prochain jusqu'à lors ce sont
500 personnes incarcérées et 31
établissements pénitentiaires qui ont
accueilli des ateliers et des rencontres
avec des auteurs comme vous le voyez sur
ces images de Vosges télévision une
opportunité rare et originale dans le
milieu carcéral pour favoriser l'accès à
la culture écoutez ces propos récoltés
par Marie dabiel rogovitz et Anne Didier
sur place au fur et à mesure ma plus ils
avaient lu plus avaient de mots à te
donner donc il prenait confiance il se
redressait il souriait on a vu vraiment
l'engagement qu'ils ont mis dedans à
nous harceler pour avoir tel ou tel
livre rapidement parce qu'il disait plus
vite que qu'il ne fallait le participer
à une opération d'envergure nationale et
qui est connu de tous c'est vraiment
leur permettre de participer à ce choix
que leur parole entendu que que leurs
émotions soient portées soit partagée
voilà et c'est donc jeudi prochain que
sera dévoilé à Paris le premier lauréat
du Prix Goncourt des détenus
l'annonce de sa production le mois
dernier avait déclenché une vive
polémique la masse côte des Jeux
olympiques de Paris sera finalement
produite à 50% en France en Bretagne
précisément une fierté évidemment pour
l'entreprise fabricante et ses salariés
à cette occasion 40 employés viennent
d'être embauchés reportage de Raphaël
Tondreau Gautier pour TVR sur place
regardez
difficile de se concentrer quand les
projecteurs sont braqués vers soi entre
500 et 600000 petites peluches comme
celle-ci seront fabriqués ici à la
Guerche de Bretagne alors forcément on
n'est pas peu fier
que ça passe découvrir notre entreprise
aussi au-delà de des mascottes
[Musique]
de ma vie comme ça enfin à la télé puis
voilà à grande échelle c'est c'est un
honneur aussi en fait qu'un entreprise
revient de loin en 2019 les ateliers de
maelo tradition sont rachetés par Le
Parisien Doudou et Compagnie un
déménagement des embauché quelques
formations après les couturières ont du
pain sur la planche en parallèle des
autres peluches elle fabriqueront à
terme près de 50% des mascottes du
groupe l'autre moitié est en fabriquée
en Chine il y a un nom fin compte on a
commencé ici on était cinq personnes il
y avait rien de tout ce que vous voyez
on a été formé par Madame Brault donc
qui était avancé gérant voilà moi je
viens de vraiment d'un autre vraiment un
autre univers et ben si on est super
fiers pour accélérer la cadence une
quarantaine d'employés de
supplémentaires va être embauché
l'objectif une production de 1000
peluches par jour le pari c'est de
conserver les emplois c'est-à-dire que
parallèlement Paris 2024 c'est un levier
colossal tout l'enjeu de notre équipe
c'est de prévoir tous les outils toutes
les gammes tous les modèles tous les
partenariats qui vont nous permettre de
maintenir l'usine pour l'occasion le
grand patron de l'événement a fait le
déplacement Tony estanguay et même
reparti avec sa propre peluche comptez
39 euros pour ce frige c'est son nom
made in France et surtout made in
Ille-et-Vilaine
et si au collège les heures dites de
colle étaient remplacées par des actions
pour l'environnement marin l'idée
pourrait surprendre les plus jeunes qui
nous écoutent c'est pourtant bien à
l'idée déployée par l'association j'aime
ma mère en Corse où elle vient de mener
une opération des élèves vont participer
à une collecte de déchets sur la plage
bien plus qu'une punition une bonne
action pour la préservation des espaces
naturels écoutez à ce propos
l'initiateur de ce projet au micro
d'Angèle Ricciardi de la rédaction de
via télépasée sur place
ça m'est arrivé d'être collé quand
j'étais plus jeune et finalement ça
serait pas grand chose on était sur une
table à gratter du papier je dis bah ce
serait bien de transformer ses heures en
quelque chose de efficace et de
d'intelligence et puis quelque chose qui
peut servir à d'autres ce qui est
important c'est pas une c'est pas une
punition c'est-à-dire que déjà il faut
que les élèves soient volontaires c'est
pas ils sont pas obligés de venir donc
ça c'est important les parents sont
d'accord donc si le gamin n'a pas envie
de venir il vient pas il fait son de
colle à l'intérieur mais c'est vraiment
une démarche volontaire de leur part
voilà est l'un des déchets les plus
polluants pour l'environnement et les
milieux marins ce sont évidemment les
mégots de cigarettes on estime chaque
année qu'entre 20 et 25000 tonnes de
mégots sont jetés en France un fléau qui
impacte bien sûr les espaces publics et
les collectivités ces dernières tentent
de réagir à Bougival dans les Yvelines
l'Amérique vient d'investir dans des
marqueurs au sol pour sensibiliser les
fumeurs au portage de Julien Leroy pour
tv78 la chaîne des Yvelines
donc vous avez des résidus de mégot là
derrière
et là il y a un Amal face à ces actes
d'incivilité la mairie de Bougival passe
à l'action des clou en laiton ont été
installés en novembre au niveau des
avaloirs d'eau de la commune objectif de
ce dispositif ne rien jeter ici commence
la mer rappeler aussi toyens les
conséquences environnementales du jet de
mégots dans l'espace public généralement
présent en bord de mer ses clous peuvent
surprendre dans une ville yvelinoise
Bougival est une ville d'eau puisque
nous sommes le long de la Seine et tous
les mégots qui arrivent par les offres
pluviales dans les abaloirs se déverse
dans la Seine en masse et suit donc le
parcours de la Seine et se jette dans la
mer
pour un coup de 2000 euros à la commune
Bougival espère un investissement
utile chaque agent de propreté passe une
heure par jour au ramassage des mégots
selon la mairie c'est très difficile de
verbaliser les personnes
la démarche aujourd'hui deux Bougival et
de sensibiliser de manière pédagogique
tout ça toujours très sympa
effectivement de faire prendre
conscience aux gens que bah attention la
mère c'est pas des milliers de
kilomètres c'est là c'est tout de suite
maintenant ça va pas les empêcher de
fumer ça peut peut-être leur donner
mauvaise conscience si j'ai par terre
mais voilà je pense pas que je pense pas
que ça va faire changer leur habitude
d'après une étude de la Commission
européenne les mégots de cigarettes sont
le déchets plastiques le plus retrouvé
sur les plages européennes derrière les
bouteilles le ministère de la transition
écologique estime entre 20 000 et 25000
tonnes la quantité de mégots jetés en
France chaque année
Porsche Maserati Bugatti ou encore
Bentley les plus belles voitures du
monde étaient exposées lors du salon Top
Marques à Monaco un événement automobile
unique consacré au modèle les plus rares
de la planète et dont vous retrouverez
les coulisses dans le prochain numéro de
l'émission Monte-Carlo Riviera diffusé
dimanche sur TV5 Monde en attendant
voici un extrait consacré vous allez le
voir non pas à des voitures mais à une
moto volante c'est spectaculaire
regardez
l'innovation est aussi au rendez-vous à
topmark et cette année les véhicules
volants sont à l'honneur car aujourd'hui
se déplacer dans les airs n'est plus une
fiction mais une réalité c'est le cas de
la x-tourismo une moto volante made in
Japan
[Musique]
to people
des véhicules volants qui peuvent être
aujourd'hui utilisés dans des conditions
particulières en fonction des pays
voilà pour en savoir un peu plus sur
cette moto étonnante et sur les plus
beaux véhicules au monde et mes
rendez-vous dimanche à 12h20 et mardi à
19h pour voir le prochain numéro de
monte-carl Riviera sur TV5 Monde 5
hectares de décors sublimes et
d'illumination féerique le festival des
lanternes vient de débuter à Montauban
une fois encore cette cinquième édition
en mettant lumière la culture chinoise
et les richesses locales comme le rugby
d'ici la fin du festival le 3 février
prochain les organisateurs espèrent
battre un record d'affluence reportage
pour le moins scintillant de Geoffrey
Priol pour via Occitanie regardez
les lumières scintillent à nouveau pour
le festival des lanternes mais cette
fois-ci à Montauban la nouvelle ville
haute de l'événement et même si pour les
inauguration plusieurs visiteurs
connaissaient déjà le festival la magie
reste toujours la même magnifique toutes
ces couleurs tous ces personnages un bon
moment et un bon moment ça fait rêver un
peu
c'est fait pour ça je pense et c'est
très bien que qu'on puisse le voir
directement et je crois que le site du
cours Foucault convient parfaitement à
cette manifestation la scénographie du
festival a été revu pour mieux s'adapter
aux nouveaux lieux mais avec toujours
les incontournables pandas dinosaures il
immense vasque des 9 dragons entièrement
porcelaine et sur les quatre hectares
d'exposition plusieurs hommages à
Montauban ont été ajoutés les
parachutistes qui sont bien présents sur
la ville seront représentés avec une
multitude de parachutes mais aussi
l'équipe de rugby on est sur des terres
de rugby comme je dis souvent et l'USM
contre une équipe de dragons méchant
dragon mais l'USM gagne et il y a on le
voit c'est normal 60 000 billets ont
déjà été achetés pour le festival des
lanternes et les organisateurs espèrent
dépasser les 400 000 visiteurs d'ici le
3 février
[Musique]
voilà il y a Saint-Étienne c'était la
Sainte Barbe que l'on fêtait récemment
en hommage au passé minier de la ville à
cette occasion habitants et passant ont
pu assister comme vous le voyez sur ces
images de nos partenaires de TL7 sur
place à un défilé et un feu d'artifice
de bien belles images festives et
musicales de la télévision de la Loire
et puis bien évidemment ce mois de
décembre nous ne pouvions pas nous
quitter sans découvrir d'autres belles
vues des fêtes de Noël cette semaine
direction Limoges ou jusqu'au 31
décembre prochain les habitants peuvent
profiter d'une ambiance toujours aussi
réjouissante ça peint des corps et
marcher à l'esprit de Noël a envahi
toute la ville avec notamment la façade
de la mairie des images bien belles de
la rédaction de 7 à Limoges sur place
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition du
Grand JT des territoires merci de nous
avoir suivis on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]